people like oh you called it I think I
guess
you
guess you called it exactly yeah and he
did twice he did two different attempts
a Tak down and a choke yeah you know I
wish I could brag or you you know but
doesn't even mean being humble for the
rest of you that didn't call us figure
it
out now the fights at UFC 294 be a lot
tougher to call and I'll try my best but
when it comes to this you know YouTuber
influencer stuff yeah yeah oh did it end
in a DQ okay okay oh you called it oh
cool that doesn't make me feel good I
did we all were fre what the immediately
we were like holy [__] you actually I
didn't even think it was a thing but
until my brother's like hey man
internet's going crazy if you call him
like really we want make it the
title